greetings from podcast Ville its
Thursday the 25th of April you bad
[ __ ] the church is brought to
you by zip recruiter hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
can go where hiring is simple fast and
smart a place where growing businesses
connect to qualified candidates that
place is zip recruit accom slash church
and right now the church family can try
zip recruiter for free that's right free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter com slash Church that's zip
recruited com slash Church again
zip recruited com slash Church a smarter
way to hire the church is also brought
to you by hims let me ask you a question
I don't know if you know this jack but
it's unusual in fact up to 39 percent of
men experiencing it's the fun ending to
quickly you want to maintain your
erections for a longer time the deeper
issue is in timing premature ejaculation
can make men feel down on themselves
creating a vicious cycle of sexual
anxiety trust me I lived through it
most guys my guys aren't thrilled at the
thought of opening up a doc to a doctor
about their performance problems if you
know what I mean but having a positive
mental state is good in and of itself
and it can also be the key to better
lovemaking and help guys gain control
and crunch time hits that's what we call
a win-win situation this is what hymns
could do fee and right now a special
offer to my to the church family to get
you started for ten dollars you like
Joey ten dollars ten dollars go at for
hymns calm slash Coco to get started
that's four hymns and for hims dot-com
slash Coco to get started see the full
the website for full details and safety
information let's get this party started
kick this [ __ ] meal Lee we're
here mother [ __ ] this Chelsea's kid was
here
the flying Jew is here but most
importantly your ear you bad
[ __ ] what's up Chelsea what's
up how's it goin you know trying to put
the pieces together everyday trying to
run through it's been a rough [ __ ]
week rough couple weeks nipsey Russell
you know
people dying I don't know what the [ __ ]
is going on people getting shot dad I'm
[ __ ] hmm and the bad neighborhoods
and we're just trying to put the pieces
together
what's going on with you just drinking
my crack right now my notes are cold
brew shout out to Tate caveman Colin so
is that coffee or is that [ __ ] it's
cold Braille so what's cold brew I have
no idea
walk me that's cold with oxygen levels
and [ __ ] in it yeah I don't like it's
very acidic I don't like the taste of
coffee but I like the way that this
makes me feel it makes me feel like I
did a speedball and yeah you don't do
coffee I just started drinking coffee
III milk when I like it with half and
half I like a [ __ ] black cup of
coffee straw I wish I did
gross put some [ __ ] nice fake sugar
yeah
nice black cup of coffee it's not black
and sugar I do [ __ ] for expressos at
night really at not yet yeah like I
could do four of them like it six of had
to go to store it and uh-huh I'll do a
four shot at like eight how do you fall
asleep midnight I could fall I did come
for 30 years I could fall asleep on
rhyme would fall asleep dragon redbull
could you can you fall asleep on coke
no okay I mean it's funny a couple we
yeah yesterday or Sunday I was gonna go
to bed in the date I don't know what I
was thinking about this thing I saw
about 10 years ago there was a case that
they couldn't figure out a murder count
I'm not a murderer
the guy died but he died in the sleep
and they couldn't figure out the guy
never drank he never the drug she stayed
home every night and with his wife it
was the co-writer
they couldn't figure out what he had
done and that the autopsy they you know
I looked at his nose he had been
addicted to coke for you
but what his thing was he would do coke
to go to sleep I knew people that would
do a line of coke to go up because what
goes up must come down
say we do a little line of coke before
they went to sleep and they would keep
him up for 20 and then the crash I'm one
little line they would ride that wave
length to sleep I don't know how people
could do it that's what this guy was
doing that's [ __ ] crazy interview
his wife was like 60 and she was like it
was funny he would come up every night
and then go into his own private
bathroom and being there for like five
minutes so after the autopsy came back
they went into the bathroom and they
found [ __ ] mirrors an ounce half of
coke he was just an old [ __ ] koepka
that figured out he wouldn't do it in
the daytime he just do a line at night
and then go to bed well you know people
so there was like two different types of
people like people who are addicted to
coke like they get high from coke and
they're awake but if and then there's
people who do pills and the people who
like pills they go up to but people who
don't like pills do you know what I mean
it's the opposite and people who like if
I took pills I don't like pills that
makes me sleepy and the kind of people
who like pills when they do coke it
makes them sleepy do you know what I
mean I explained it cuz I know we've
been we'd like one day I fell asleep in
the podcast about two months ago with
Steve Samar we had eaten edibles had
been longer
we had edibles but it was the vicodin I
popped like a half a Viking and a half a
happy pill they put me out yeah but when
you read about them they have speeding
them they have caffeine in them that's
why they they make you feel like that
vicodin vicodin
yeah core local Norco Norco and that
goes to have so much I don't know what
the word is speed it's caffeine I think
caffeine or something else in it that's
supposed to keep you up that's why the
pain goes away and I and then I'm being
in Vegas like two years ago and with our
friend he gave me a Norco and I remember
going upstairs to the room and I could
not fall asleep mmm I was up so they
affect you well do we take two of those
capsules okay I think we took two of
those are strong a happy pill wait
what's that ecstasy we call vicodin or
know COEs actually my friend in Vegas
calls me happy pills so we just kept ya
happy pills it's not that we you know so
why he wants to laugh somebody get
surgery and they'll go his tool yeah and
I'll put them in the bag of tricks and
they'll stay they'll stay in there for
six months and then
when I go [ __ ] it let's see the local
maybe I'll go work back to hurt system
and we that's right there black pop to
local I couldn't stay awake hmm those
people they poppin or go and it reverses
I don't know much about ya pills make me
tired and coke makes me awake I can't
sleep on coke I'm sober now but I was
all before now I'll have three years
next month
but I because I was a really bad coke ad
how old were you when you started I
started when I was 15
no [ __ ] yes yes yeah I skipped the last
period of high school skipped art class
went to the jungle gym and I did coke
with my friend and I was like I love
this and I just did it yeah did it up
until like 26 but I've been sober
technically for six years but I relapsed
three years ago
I'm coke yeah drinking and coke for a
couple weeks and then now I'm back well
made you relapse I was dating a guy who
was an [ __ ] and he cheated on me and
he like rubbed it in my face and it's
just like it just made me snap for some
reason you know a lot of people who are
addicts and alcoholics they get [ __ ]
up because they can't like feel their
feelings so basically like I don't know
it was just like too much for me and I
think I had been in a lot of shitty
relationships and it felt like
everything kind of just like hit me at
once you know what I mean like dealing
with the same type of person and I just
kind of like snapped and I just like had
to drink and I just partied really
really hard and then I had to get sober
because I can't handle it anymore oh
he's off the wagon for it was two weeks
what were you thinking about two weeks I
was out of my mind and I'm so glad I
didn't go to the store cuz I've never
been to the store [ __ ] up cuz you know
when I started going there I was sober
but I stayed away on my relapse because
I was like I know I'm just gonna get
high and like stay weird [ __ ] to people
you know but I know I was like texting
like comics like I love your special
like high on coke just like that person
that was bad Eric Griffin just like
texting them at all hours it's just
being crazy
it's
it's a weird [ __ ] drunk mm-hm I can
never imagine me relapse not go again
it's been 11 years oh really
I can't yeah I imagine like people have
done it in front of me doesn't even
spark a hair or I just can't imagine
yeah I'd imagine it's my favorite thing
it was mind also yeah I couldn't focus
okay and I still have it's been 11 years
but the anxiety I get at night was the
same anxiety I was getting from what it
was time to do coke mm-hmm
like I still lose it would come into my
mind you'd have to share 55 yes 7:55 I
was off and running like I had I
couldn't even think I would call him and
go over and pick it up and they would be
in my pocket that will put me at peace
nothing I was doing it I know exactly
what you mean if I if I had it in my
pocket it's the security the spiritus is
rested now I have to just go to the
store and do my spot if I could get away
with my spot and then on the way off
right off the original room I would go
right into the bathroom there would not
even be a hesitation there would be hey
meet me in the bar no but the whole time
I got a pee real bad like go right into
that bathroom and that was my boom boom
boom four bumps go to the ball get a
[ __ ] Jack and Coke and then the what
and then I wouldn't get [ __ ] up down
there once I do the Jack and Coke it was
time to go home I'll finish getting
[ __ ] up like I didn't like getting
[ __ ] up I think in all these I was
down there snorting coke I think I
stayed to drink maybe five times and
those seven eight years like maybe five
times I stay that night you got to see
everybody else coked up and people got
to see you coked up but I hadn't in sit
up there earlier where I found that
people are watching you up there yeah we
got to be really careful up there so I
knew not to [ __ ] around do you get home
like I was I'm not I have other issues
but drugs have never been my thing on
strong edibles I feel a little bit
hungover the next day but if you're
doing coke all night how like how do you
feel the next day and then like how many
nights a week are you doing it when I
was doing first of all you feel like you
want to die the next day you're so hung
over you feel like you want to throw
yourself out the window and I do coke
and
I just can't talk anymore you know what
I mean like 16 hours usually for me was
like my limit so I'd like drink and do
coke for like 16 hours I'd go home at
like 5:00 p.m. the next day you know son
still out trying to get a cab in the
city no cabs are stopping because it's
always rush hour by the time I'm
finished and you just feel like you're
like [ __ ] dying the worst that's
happening to take the subway home after
a night of doing coke all night when
you're coming down I have like the worst
come down like trying to find my way
home stories and then you're just like
dying and then you take like Tuesday at
bar you know two xanax bars to fall
asleep and then you wake up and you do
the whole thing over again the next day
so I was doing it like five days a week
I was like a really big party girl in
New York I you know it was like a club
person and she was or you would commute
every night oh you lived in this I lived
in the city I went to college in Hawaii
out of high school and then I
transferred to the city and I went to
pace downtown did you really yeah so you
went to the University of Y first yeah
it was cool but I was bored after the
first year you went down to get away
from this [ __ ] it was the only school
gone into I was I wasn't I was not good
at school I smoked weed and I just like
I didn't care about school I got an 880
on my SATs what major communications
which means I spent a ton of money for
not related yeah yeah I mean you know
there was some fun classes in college
but I don't think I needed it when did
you decide on stand up I had always
wanted to do stand-up it just took me a
long time to do it because I was scared
you know and I first did it when I was
18 but I really didn't start more
seriously until like six years ago about
and you started in New York you were
saying earlier yeah I was doing some
mics in New York and in LA and then I
moved to LA that year so what made you
move on here I wanted to do The
Groundlings I said have you been there
lately
yeah well I I started doing UCB in New
York and then I wanted to switch and do
growling so I did that for two years
but then I just switched to stand up
because it was just too much for me in
the beginning of me start like wanting
to get serious about stand up I was like
I can't do all these other things I just
need a focus right now on stand ups I
don't compare UCB theatre to the comedy
stuff hmm well I did used to be in New
York I didn't do used to be out here but
my experience was that everyone is
supportive of each other and not that
everyone is not with stand-up but I do
think like you know with improv
everyone's clapping all the time after
you finish and like everyone like wants
you to do better and they all help each
other and I do think obviously is like
that and stand-up but I also think your
friends laugh at you when you bomb in
the back you know what I mean so there's
a little and you're also on your own
when you do stand-up you know you're not
working with other people I personally
like to be at doing stand-up better I
like to you know be on my own and not
have to like rely on someone else
onstage with me and you know just do
that it's funny because when I got here
I thought about going to one of those
places like just going just to see and
then somebody I think it was Paul he was
like you're crazy
don't go down there with those people
those people whacked up with the
education you're getting here but I
always believe them like the more
broader you were the better you'd be at
stand-up just if you just go touch it
and then the ImprovOlympic opens up
around the corner for me where I lived
in Hollywood and I took a few classes in
there and I think midway through the
second class I'm like I'm not coming in
on more it's like I had just gonna [ __ ]
this because they used to have a
stand-up show at improv Olympic this is
going back 2006 2005 2004 like kid you
not guys they had an improv dad it was
improv Olympic was an improv school
Hollywood and Cohen that down the corner
huh they should be an improv school but
on Friday night somebody talked him into
doing stand-up and 11 o'clock and I
gotta tell you something
I've been for the store I've been taught
by a factory and I've been to the ice
house and in the improv in Hollywood all
those years and I saw industry nights
what they call the industry night
I had never seen so many agents like I
did that night at the improv Olympic and
I don't know what they were there to see
yeah there was nothing outrageous that
haven't been walking in there like
you're nothing like number eight and
when I went up was like thank God a
[ __ ] stand out my people were
clapping I picked I was a magician I
feel like I was like Jesus yeah you know
when I walked off him like what the [ __ ]
is going on it and when I stayed to
watch it was like improv kids trying to
do stay nothing he gets nobody but it
was just a god-awful show right and I'm
like why all these [ __ ] agency and it
made sense that's where they go they
can't be at the improv watching [ __ ]
real comedy or comedy school they gotta
come here to watch these kids and at the
improv Olympic I noticed there was a lot
of rich kids uh-huh that go there with a
dream they don't work don't do nothing
they just come here they watch their
live I think they tell their parents
like listen we want to give it a shot in
Hollywood and the parents are okay you
got a year on the credit card but if you
don't make it then you gotta come back
to work at the fruit stand or something
it was a lot of those type of guys like
David always going got six months to
make something happen you're like I'm
even [ __ ] nine years nothing's
happened yeah how's it gonna happen what
the [ __ ] are you looking for in six
months so always had a weird way of
looking at those places I thought it was
I think that the more classes you took
in your head the better you got it's
something but I don't really agree with
that I think the more you get on stage
the more you learn like every time you
get on stage you should walk off the
stage with something like I made a
mistake there I'll keep that in mind I
made a mistake there it's like when you
go work at a deli the first time you
don't get good until you cut for your
[ __ ] fingers off haha yes this is one
time when that slicer is [ __ ] and all
that you know it's the same thing with
Tommy it's it's you could study it and
read about it all you [ __ ] want and
you could watch stand-up all the [ __ ]
you want but it's one of those things
that you have to get on stage constantly
absolutely
why are you something that I've noticed
since I started is that improv and
stand-up are very like they
seem like they're connected but I've
done 18 shows where they do improv based
off of your material or I've had improv
people come to open legs and it seems
very different cuz well there is improv
and stand-up right there's people who go
up there and just wing it
I could go up there and wing it if you
like if you want me to go up there and
wing it I'll go up there and wing it
every night right what you're gonna get
is if I do six sets three of them are
gonna be [ __ ] superb and the other
three are gonna go I'm never gonna don't
rip - take it up and never go watch
stand up again okay so I could go up
there and improv with the best then go
up there fresh off the cuff and talk
about all the [ __ ] we do here like we're
talking I say all that [ __ ] the
craziness I can go up there and I get
and I'll tell you if I do six of those
sets three one will be tremendous but
the other three will be so [ __ ] bad
that you'll never want to see stand up
again so I can't take that chance
anymore right
when I first started I learned how to
improvise at them when I first started
in Boulder I tried to be Louis L'Amour
we all trying to be writers but I
realized that I couldn't write five
minutes every [ __ ] Tuesday like
nobody had to write three minutes from
Tuesday the Tuesday but five or seven
minutes unless I improvised and then the
guy would always tell me do ten I can't
[ __ ] do ten minutes he had cuz I had
it right these are the same the reason
why I haven't do new material every week
is because the same people it was the
same people came to this comedy thing
it was muchas who came they would pay
1495 for prime rib shrimp and all that
[ __ ] then they'd get a comedy ticket so
when you walked up on stage you had to
get him out of the steak like they would
any eat the steak they weren't there for
you they were there for 1495 for the
steak so I would have to go up there
first and I bombed for so long in my
mind if I just made him lift the head
from the steak that was an applause hmm
so I had to give him new material but I
shortly after about six or seven months
I realized you know what [ __ ] this
material [ __ ] I'm just gonna come up
here and [ __ ] with them so for 18 months
I did great as a stand-up I relied on my
improv skills which I've been
improvising all my life but when it
comes to nitty-gritty that improv
izing didn't come back to me there's
times I got like a set list of 40
minutes and you go on stating the 20
minute mark you improvise for 10 and
you're like oh [ __ ] that I could pull
off but this still has to be the
foundation still has to be there I just
can't go out and in New York when you
start New York you pick up a bad habit
that's 12 on the people hmm that's a bad
apple
you mean crowd work yeah really in New
York everybody in this crowd work ah and
that's what we're that's why I really
got into that bad habit I call
groundwork crowd work like when you get
a rebound and instead of putting it back
up you dribble the ball and then you go
up now you got five guys on you when you
dribble the ball you made that you it's
a magnet the ball is a magnet so you put
it down fight and it's a hard habit to
break grab the rebound instead of
grabbing and putting it back up getting
a rebound
that's what 12 into the audience is
because when you come to hell you can't
talk to the audience first time an agent
goes to see you walking around with the
audience
don't walk right out right that's what
you can see the amateur LA guy and a
professional how they got when people
move to town for mother like Texas is
chatty a while economics that work Texas
they're chatty and New York City is
definitely chatted to go right up on
stage how y'all doing tonight great they
have a beer and a hand they're cool then
they put the beer down they take the mic
what do you do sir well your electrician
you've been together and they work it
from there
some people are brilliant at it some
people phenomenal it but you're gonna
have rough nights and there's some
nights of people are like you know what
we really came to see stand-up and the
roughest when I ever saw was he kept
asking the same three questions you know
he wasn't getting equally the answers he
wanted and it was like 20 minutes and
like people around what's happened know
that that's what I'm saying I'm like
when you have a real show you can't talk
to people and then you have to when you
learn when you're at the store you'll
learn quick that you can't talk to
people because unless you're Rick yes he
does well a lot of people don't like
[ __ ] with Rick because that reason
because when you follow Rick now that
gives those people permission to talk to
you mmm
well sure you want to be a headline and
do it that's good but like as a feature
I you should do it the headliners it
pulled me aside ago can we talk to you
for saying stop talking yeah no no they
talk they think they got the right to
talk to me right cuz it opens it up I
think it's a whole like you a go to the
store and watch somebody go up that does
that Rick like Rick Ingram is good he's
been doing it for a long time but if you
ask Rick pulled beside ago Rick a lot of
Congress complain about you doing that a
couple of them don't like it I don't
know that yeah a couple of them don't
like it because you talking to the
audience now every comic that comes up
here some [ __ ] idiots gonna say so
mmm so that's the school of thought that
when you start I want you to improvise
when you're at the fourth wall or
flappers or whatever the [ __ ] you do
open mics improvise I'd rather you
improvise I wouldn't put up with that
[ __ ] yeah I wouldn't put up with that
come on of then I'm just saying the joke
in the joke behind it's gonna die it's a
teen comics in the room you might as
well improvise right working on that
muscle just go up there calls that [ __ ]
you wrote is not gonna go over at these
that open my place it's so why are you
doing it you're not gonna get those two
real gauge of those jokes your friend of
a live audience so I'd rather you bring
a tape recorder and you start talking
three minutes of five that they give you
you don't have a minute of pearls then
go up and write it down and Gulman write
it down and all the listening ready now
and at the end of the week that's why
they call it work or not you're just
talking I'd rather go up there and take
a chance in twelve like I'd do it the
Icehouse then go up there with jokes
that I wrote the try because I'm gonna
be [ __ ] I'm gonna be thinking of
those words mm-hmm I'd rather just talk
and then afterward Chelsea to say that
line you said it was really good write
that down then you'll say that line you
said was really good right now I think
it's a little different because with
improv it's a lot of something crowd
work if they ask for suggestions yeah
well you're creating a scene it's it's
different from like cuz you're not
stand-up is obviously writing jokes and
like performing them on stage stand-up
is going up with several Pete
and doing a scene it's it's like a whole
different it's weird i saw someone do a
one-person improv like this this is the
worst thing I've ever seen mm-hmm just
by yourself yeah it's uh UCB and
growlings has great shows though you
know there's a lot of really talented
people up there for sure well there's a
lot of people who be like is that the
way to go if you were gonna move here as
an actor and like I want to be the next
movie star like it seems like a lot of
the comedic actors come from those
places they might not be stand-ups but
they come from that a lot of a lot of
actors do stand-up because they think
now right which is like cuz they think
that's the thing to do right now so they
got me food it's like a whole you know
so a lot of people just do that stuff to
get famous or to put it on there you
know a lot of actors are told do an
improv class put it on your resume
that's what people like to see when you
audition for stuff they make like - okay
yeah yeah yeah I don't I just don't like
I think I look back now at the 22 years
I've been in town and all the [ __ ]
scams I thought about doing like in LA
like all the stupid [ __ ] cuz they're all
scams like what a in class I am
breathing and motivational and all that
shit's just a scam you know you think
about all the scams that they run out
there and what these poor kids come out
of college and come out here with their
parents hard earned dollar and they give
it to Joe Schmo stand-up school the guys
in there right on the spot and [ __ ]
down I'm saying guys never done a spot
in [ __ ] town or they go to an acting
coach and just ask for the first day can
I see your resume uh-huh uh-huh let me
see your resume I understand you could
be like Phil Jackson Phil Jackson was a
horrible [ __ ] basketball player but
he ended up being one of the best
coaches of all time
I understand that happens but like I
know an acting guy that was an acting
coach I saw him one time act on the TV
show and it was [ __ ] horrendous
it was [ __ ] horrendous yeah I was at
some people's house like all while I'm
here my buddy's gonna be on a coke case
like this had to be 10 years ago when I
put the episode it was god-awful
and this guy today is in charge of like
a mise the school somewhere all right
yeah like he's a director of the school
like oh but give that [ __ ] mutt money
means I'm not a nice guy yeah he's a
nice guy
but what can he teach you right he's
booked two guest stars dirty is I got a
[ __ ] pet monkey that could book two
guest spots in two years you know you
got a hundred audition he's gonna book
something Yeah right 20 [ __ ] years
I've never even my wife did acting for a
year and she booked [ __ ]
international something with a billboard
so if you stay in town long enough you
audition you'll get something some real
[ __ ] high you because you know
commercial all you need to is to fog up
the bottom of glass it's not yeah a real
talent he's booking a [ __ ] commercial
when you chick I got fat guy and he's
wiggling with a tie around the stomach
and it says [ __ ] you know Pennzoil
whatever you know did he go to Hackett
did he go to improv school tour yeah we
go do you bring a coach here to go okay
when you wiggle breathe and let the tire
go around you know you just put the
[ __ ] tire I did this is a kid like
only heavier you know but people really
want to have their hands help in this
town like they really do that I never I
know I just never when I went to improv
Olympic and then I went to the store
after that improv Olympic experience I
said that's it that's why I'm it's he
calls it the university that's why you
go from the belly room to like a paid
unpaid regular not a paid regular there
was a system there was a system and if
you want to work there as a doorman you
got worked there as a doorman to help
with the [ __ ] bills or whatever there
were so many options that they gave you
just sitting in the back and watching
it's incredible think we're sitting in
the back like go do your spots everybody
go do your spots look do your 8 o'clock
and stand on line and flap and then jump
up and down some Mexican room and
Lionsgate or whatever that's called
whatever the [ __ ] off the 5 all these
guys just do not on the way home you're
just gonna go home and watch TV anyway
go get popped by that time twelve
o'clock there's tons of meters on the
[ __ ] sunset you go and sit in the
back of the room I could tell you a
comic that I worked with as a [ __ ]
host
Myrtle Beach and he told me that when he
was hosting as I'm moving that way you
had the storming oh yeah come by and say
hello when you say it to somebody you're
like what his chances coming by say
[ __ ] came by and said hello like
what the [ __ ] are you doing here
and never came to me and asked me for
nothing he would he go you can you get
me a seat inside and he would just wait
and wait and wait I watch them free here
at night I get off the original and his
two little eyeballs be in the back and
in those days there was only eight
people there wasn't no 600 people whose
day night there was eight people so I'd
always see him then after six months ago
night he got a door job at The Comedy
Store then I saw him on stage today that
guy's jason Lucas oh yeah now he's
married doesn't do stand-up much he's a
today but for a year I saw Jason and
I'll go Jason don't you work and he goes
I gotta be at work at 7:00 no but I come
and watch movie every night you yeah
like his need to come here like a call
11 o'clock 11:30 it's at that old one
it's in the back yeah it's been an
incredible education working there and
just getting to watch people every night
you know for five years haven't you seen
yeah yeah Silverman yeah everybody I
can't think of who no one like off the
top of my head I can't think yeah it's
incredible
no it's and that's why I like that I
like watching like I hate come on the
Comedy Store and I sit down and people
want to Bob now I'm sitting that Mitzi's
ruff I'm [ __ ] high as [ __ ] I'm just
watch the stand-up guy yeah I'm getting
into their ass like I'm getting sucked
in by by them you know you watch a
special on Netflix it's funny but you're
not getting sucked it's not the same you
muggins yeah you got to watch it live
being sucked in and I knew nothing like
before I got on stage I watched zero
stand-up lie zero from 50 yards I saw
Dave Chappelle and that black dude in
1982 a Washington Square Park when there
be a circle around Dave Chappelle right
and the other guy that he started the
main guy
with Charlie Barnet now that was the
main guy but Chappelle would be his
understudy he was like 15 when you
talked to Chappelle next time bring up
Charlie bar that his eyes light up
that's his mentor Wow Charlie Barnet was
supposed to be honest an ally
Betty Murphy took his Bacchus Charlie
couldn't read but if Charlie could read
there'd be no any Murphy yeah it's how
good Charlie was the fact he was just on
the other night I was strolling to the
channels and that movie was uh
and I was I came on for a bit and I had
to leave and I laughed my ass off I
forget what he's on the movie mr. t and
it was something like be TV at night
late night Don I was like eh 8:30
quarter nine then I stand I asked my
wife I go what stop that for a second DC
cab DC cab I haven't heard of that and I
laughed my ass off watching him remember
mr. t but Charlie Barnet was the one
that was supposed to be the next big
thing he's not HIV and everything he was
the real deal Wow he was a junkie he was
a [ __ ] HIV but it was a heroin guy hmm
and he was the one that you know would
wet I guess Dave Chappelle will come up
from DC to New York on the weekends or
everyday and Charlie Barnet would just
go you know watch the Square Park is he
would just go off there like there was
those little uh artists art by the
artist death you know that there's dead
bodies buried under Washington Square
Park used to be did you know that no
yeah it used to be like it used to be a
cemetery so there's like thousands of
dead bodies buried under Washington
Square Park but I haven't be a cemetery
like in 1700 its grows in my hometown
there's thousands of cemeteries really
like my hometown block Bergen New Jersey
I found a bridge there right over the
tunnel they have tons of cemeteries and
I remember if you take the fence by the
projects by 64
58 Street they used to be a fence and it
would cut you through to 46 feet so we
would take that fence
one night I take a [ __ ] in the funeral
in the cemetery tonight Freddie Prinze
died and I had to take a [ __ ] this out
my old I'm an old man people know
Freddie Prinze jr. I'm talking about
Freddie Prinze senior he killed himself
I can 77 78 79 one of those years he
killed himself and I was walking home
and I remember going man I take a [ __ ]
and it was [ __ ] freezing huh and I
pulled my pants down but I double
checked on the grave cuz I go how much
this guy just got buried yeah would you
wipe that flower top bags there was a
bunch of brown bags that people had I
took as many as I could it was [ __ ]
freezing huh I was a kid eighth grade
yeah and I pulled my pants to the front
and I [ __ ] but I peed in my pants oh my
god I went to put the pants back on they
were froze now I had a walk home
how long was that walk like an hour well
when I looked at the it wasn't even a
tombstone it was a two sticks put
together like but they had been like
finished like it was good wood and it
said like 1822 to 1899 I'm like what do
I do
yes that business is [ __ ] you yeah
that one part of a cemetery that was
really old but but then there's another
building what they built on and they
said there was a cemetery and the
buildings having problems now really
yeah and yeah in LA or New Jersey yeah
Jersey right there okay because all
those things along the river or like
what George Washington fought the
Indians like if you go to Fort Lee the
other side of the bridges were your
friend
yeah chest is the other side of the
bridge if you go on that Fort Lee bridge
and you walk off George Washington and
you go underneath there's a park there
you've been to that Park it was a little
stroll park there they have all the
cannons and cannonballs from George
Washington oh I think I read a strip me
yeah yeah you have to walk up that hill
you walk under the bridge and you cross
the street you cross a not bad pass
you cross whatever that's River Road
whatever that term where Riverdale is
River Road
but is that Riverdale no Fort Lee okay
it's a Fort Lee New Jersey where the
past and forth so right underneath there
is where you there's a little trail and
you can eat lunch at the top and they
have those things either put quarters in
ya city and should have like three of
them right it's smaller we're having I'm
sure you never stop shooting if I don't
take a [ __ ] in before Lee thing the
small band Joy I would walk back from
the bridge and then walk underneath it
be a sunny day ax and you could go up
there roller join you smoke and look at
the New York skyline where's the
weirdest place you took a [ __ ] yeah I I
don't think I'm [ __ ] out believe I
almost [ __ ] I came close once in the
John's grocery store John yeah I almost
I am wide like you know when you're
walking you have to stop walking for a
few pretending like you're looking at
something like in the middle of an aisle
that was the worst middle of an aisle
yeah I just like it was like if I move
I'm gonna [ __ ] that was the worst one
and I can think of but I III I was a kid
I had a bedwetting problem but bins I
never did all the time I would we use oh
yeah oh really you never did it no I
couldn't go to sleepovers
oh that sucks how do you mean you stop
thirteen someone like them yeah look at
it like white I wouldn't drink at night
it was terrible do you still when you
drink no well I don't drink that much
but it's been a few years but if
everyone said like I've had the dreams
once where you think you're gonna you
know him let me wake up and then there's
pee but it's better I had a plastic
mattress for a while as a kid it was not
good they would beat you poppy
no I don't take it away have you ever
hooked up with a squirter yes once but
you weren't bothered by it I loved it
yeah because you felt yeah oh you had
something in common face no I didn't
know what's gonna happen so I just did
did you drink the squirt you know I know
I didn't know it just said I'm not gonna
do the joke I have about it but just he
came out onto the sheets
yeah and then we know we only hooked
think that one time but I would love I
would love if I knew I would love to
date a girl who's courted that would be
great but you wouldn't drink the juice
anyway I'm not gonna drink it with a
straw comes out your fingers I'll eat
the [ __ ] its core it's a yeah you open
your mouth like like a water fountain
encompasses cover everything like you
treat hummus you'd be in good shape you
know that I'm a [ __ ] like that you
first of all go to Thomas ass is
disgusting like the only people I love
it was hummus no it's not
are you she's married she don't need to
eat ass no more I know he wants me to
yes you let me do this yeah but you
might want her ass but I don't thank you
she look I don't know even worse every
woman loves a ton of their ass I don't I
swear I special you put two finger Louis
in there [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
then it's brand new I don't know okay I
can sleep with this don't think that
much yeah I don't know oh my god you
know either
uh yeah no thank you I don't I don't
that's disgusting
but squirt squirting would be awesome I
had a weird one it didn't it didn't
spray it kind of just was like like the
chicken dirt well chicken honor I didn't
see that why would you watch that you
were too busy watching orange is the new
purple like in dirt when Tommy Lee's
eating the girl brings all those people
- yes the chick just sits down he starts
eating a [ __ ] he said guys you ready
you ready
he pulls his head away that's [ __ ]
shooting water oh [ __ ] at a party that's
a great party I like a [ __ ] party so
it's pretty amazing I've never done it
Alex Gordon yeah I don't think I can can
you become a squirter I don't know well
okay so you know how there's like these
sex parties and then LA there's this
place called sanctum have you ever heard
of it
yeah quickly told about it she of course
you did I went to one when I first moved
here just to like check it out and and a
cop came to like check out like the room
and we were in a room with like one of
the cops and like some other people and
I was like oh yeah I can't squirt and
the cop the cop was like all
bet that you can and he tried to like
finger me in front of like a couple of
people there it was crazy
but it didn't work but I think it's
weird that the cop who was on duty like
came there to participate are you sure
he was just not a guy in like a fake
costume or some probably that's
hysterical
what is this sex party like like that is
that really yeah it was first of all
like no one there was hot and half the
people were masks and the other half
should have been like and it was like
everyone was just like trying to be cool
it was like a wannabe Eyes Wide Shut
kind of thing but uh yeah like there was
people who are like having sex in one
room but it was very theatrical and it
felt like very forced and like there was
like another girl who was wearing a
horse mask who was [ __ ] a girl with a
strap-on who had a Marie Antoinette
costume on it was like trying too hard
that sounds like a mushroom trip that
since it was weird experience in the
city you know that's only one I ever
went to yeah no way yeah that was all in
New York City I was Plato's retreat
oh I haven't I've been to one called was
when you were ten yeah I wasn't you
attend that [ __ ] that's that's a creepy
name though tell me some weird name
growing up it was Plato's retreat I
never went there
yeah I'm not gonna tell you I went there
I never went there but I heard it was
creepy yeah friends of mine that were
animals then it just wasn't for them
that's not big well I'm from that sex
clubs and all that [ __ ] like people
would just like what the [ __ ] I've
always been too to sex things and nobody
was good-looking
right no one's home there and you Beach
one time oh god where nobody Jamaica
yeah I mean nobody nobody was there that
you want to see me even yet sometimes
you like Jesus it was a movie but I quit
I just said I can't I can't this is
disgusting it was they shot this movie I
did was a legit movie but they Shanahan
a nude resort huh what was that you're
eating breakfast so I'm driving it I
just get picked up at the airport a bomb
in it this town yeah there's these
chickens too skinny the McDonald's had
like no burgers I got a sign that said
no burgers I don't know what the [ __ ]
was going on that's on McDonald's it was
a horrible place and I spent them one
night that night I heard a bunch of
[ __ ] when I got there I can't lie to
you guys I was a little excited yeah
okay so maybe some of you suck your dick
huh right there was nobody there that
you wanted to touch it they yeah I would
suck it I think the idea of all those
kind of places are so much better than
when you actually get there that's good
you want it to be like a like a movie
like some hot [ __ ] thing and everyone
looking and they're all doing crazy
stuff but then it's just like lame weird
people yeah I guess you already have
your if you're good-looking already
having said Josh wolf had a a bar in
Seattle
Lobo Loco that's how I got to show you
some money to tears Jason so Josh wolf
had a bar that he ran it was called Lobo
local and I'm Wednesday nights
that pervert night paid me 50 bucks to
stand outside and check IDs and [ __ ] and
I would never go downstairs like the bar
was the bar and this is downstairs and
one night there was somebody and I went
downstairs and it was hard what did you
say I saw a chick that had to be 25
pounds heavier than I am right now with
a pierced [ __ ] like a click yeah yeah
like [ __ ] like uh it was like an inch
too roller and I mean nobody I'm not
trying to be rude or mean I'm just
trying to be honest nobody you've
watched Isis for a special now because
I'm looking that up by the wall she's
holding it up nobody's nobody's ever
thought of [ __ ] her she walks over
when they trim little mustache the
sideburns that was what this girl look
like she had sideburns like some girls
look cute and have like the head that
she really had like sideburns
she had hair on her neck oh she got
[ __ ] looked like they had been shot
yeah
boy not huge these guys like kissing her
neck
oh they're like putting like [ __ ]
aerosol cans in a [ __ ] really it was a
face disgusting place blow around long
like woman's Aqua Net
it was like long tube but the thinner
ones like that yeah yeah the shaving
cream joke Barbasol gel gel not the big
one
the skinny award they're putting it in
the gel in or the bottle to bottle the
bottom of it yeah they just rubbing it
in a [ __ ] and she was like guys with
dirty the chick was filthy her feet they
were had on top of a pool table it's
like they walked her from [ __ ] Oregon
Seattle a feet were black you know it
just
none of that [ __ ] really turns me on
there I could see a girl that's pretty
with dirty feet that's kind of cute I
know exactly yeah this chicks feet was
just dirty
yeah and all these white guys were round
the sucking of flappy takes like she had
a kid somewhere in her life oh it was
just terrible
yeah and then me Tripoli Jason Tebow at
the store some night a guy came in one
night and he offered this a bunch of
money to shoot uh girls gone wild
uh-huh only it was something different
it was like girls go [ __ ] crazy yeah
I think was me triply Tebow Duncan
Duncan and we had to go somewhere in the
hills they wouldn't let us take our
phones they have we had to drive up
there like they had to pick us up and we
were gonna stick the first bus back was
it nine so they wanted stand up stand up
music and [ __ ] mm-hm
why [ __ ] why you're on stage and it
was you can make them laugh who's
listening to the [ __ ] set it was
something in the end they hired
professional models white girls escorts
okay that thought they were gonna shoot
a movie Rose got up there they're like
what's going on and awesome this [ __ ]
pigs getting [ __ ]
this guy's hitting on a diving board the
world there's a heart there's a pool
that's gorgeous it's like you know
what's up E
like when you go into Laurel Canyon that
side street I got a pass it to Mohan
Mohan there was a big white people rich
you know nice house they had rented it
from somebody for the day like some
couple like go to Malibu we're just
gonna have like a little party and film
it
no they filmed this [ __ ] disgust fest
no no forget that out again you're
anxious you're like let's see what these
porno chicks look like and awesome was
sitting there talking us in here we look
over and this dude is [ __ ] this chick
he's a three she's a 6 yeah she's a not
a 10 but she's a six but you want me to
tell what the creepiest thing was her
husband was three feet from yeah I like
that
and he's like going [ __ ] a good [ __ ] a
good put in a [ __ ] mop you come in
put in the [ __ ] ass and the wife and
then afterward after she'd been come on
and spit on and flopped a I like hanging
out like swapping spit she's naked he
tried to take his clothes off people
like put tada it was it's a different
world it's not you know we talk about
stories here [ __ ] that happens the
Comedy Store somebody searched dicks I'm
gonna eat your [ __ ] that's one thing
but to live in that [ __ ] world it's
just something else like everything is
real cool no it's not cool for the pound
its drop off at the LA Zoo she don't
deserve to beat him sailing people don't
want to see that some people yeah but
the funny thing was there was a girl
there that was really pretty and when I
was on stage I was looking at her face
when she heard my standup and all these
ugly people around her [ __ ] she was
like from UC Berkeley like if I had a
picture her she had grown up a nice
family they had money she probably never
got fingered so she was 19 you know she
that's like she sucked dick but
afterward she takes the hair out
surprise and that's not what she wanted
to do in her life is give a [ __ ]
there's a backstory from the singer
Justine I could tell ya because she was
looking at me with hate in her eyes you
know there was people [ __ ] on
trampolines
Wow by 6's hard by six to seven o'clock
there was
probably six or seven couples [ __ ]
I'm not saying I'm Mel Gibson or some
looking nobody did you want like you
look over and watch him [ __ ] go Oh
God
like it was just discussed so you didn't
stand up in the daytime and there are
people [ __ ] we could stand we do the
set to open up the show then like a band
came for a while and people [ __ ]
during the band I mean like a three-hour
breathing and we had a do our show like
at 7:00 oh my god after that we were
free the whole night to just they gave
us 20 joints of peas think wow a
thousand bucks a piece
yeah but it wasn't worth it like what I
saw will stay with me forever yeah it
was just disgusting like I don't know
I'm crazy buck wild but that was really
never one of my yeah I went to a party
at Sasha grit you know sasha grey know
the name she she used to be a pretty big
porn star and I went to a party at her
house in the hills and there was just
like 10 of us 15 of us and it was a
couple of porn stars and some like dudes
from Italy and it was chill and then one
of the girls who was one of the porn
stars they had like a homemade sibian
machine Jesus which is you know like a
motorized like dildo that just that goes
like that and then they convinced one of
the girls to just get on the floor at
the party it was just like everyone was
normal until you know they brought out
the Machine and then they all couldn't
handle it and then she was just like
getting [ __ ] in front of all of us at
the party and then they turned on the
strobe light and it was just weird
especially like ten people that zulan it
was weird and I don't know and her
boyfriend was there too and he was just
like that I actually just got hit up hit
up on tinder by a woman in her in her
profile says I'm married like but I'm
polyamorous I'm like no she wants that
means she wants to have you over with
her husband no I'm not I would never go
to with her like that that's what I'm
worried about
yeah you think I don't want a husband to
get married and like find out where I
live nobody wants to watch that sounds
disgusting this thing is a red face I
mean her ass he would go either ass and
you go now
IIIi can't I don't want to I don't want
to yeah you know I love you because you
stand though I love that you Ross Allah
that night at the store you got me a lot
of trouble when I put you up when I was
hosting that night really got mad at me
what are you talking about potluck yeah
yeah I only did it once
that's ridiculous the worst night of my
life those girls aren't funny sorry I'm
not naming names but they were just
there's one of them that's still to this
day won't talk to me yeah they're crude
but they're great those girls are crazy
and they're not like comics you know
what I mean it was crazy like yeah back
in the old time Mitchie told you like I
would just blame it on Mitzi ya know
like admits he said no this is who she
wanted they were go [ __ ] you know that
my it was like hey you gotta put a girl
up I go out putting girls up and then
when I started putting girls up guys got
mad at him hey you put too many girls up
really yeah and then it was like oh my
running this [ __ ] thing was running
this day and there were just names
coming out everywhere no no you can't
put him up you gotta put her up you know
what I don't wanna know a [ __ ]
potluck is crazy potluck is crazy for
those of you don't know potluck is every
Monday night used to be Sundays too at
the store and that's when all the
employees and friends and family go up
to you know like 40 comics but there's
always people that are hovering over the
host and like people always get mad
every time like I've hosted three times
I think there's always someone who's
gonna be mad at you
you just have to ignore it and [ __ ]
enjoy your night and you know one thing
I like about your life that you're
married I like that you're beautiful
thank you like that you're funny you
have all this stuff for you but today
you have some edge to you I do like
you're the real [ __ ] dealing yeah
real rough patch in your life and you
help people out and yeah very sweet and
I've heard that about you like more than
once really yeah like though he well
she's the real deal have you heard about
him like no nobody tells me nothing I've
had a crazy life I mean you were talking
about the cokes from now yeah because I
never thought you needed drugs I've
never seen in a negative light
whatsoever like yeah you know you've
always been smiley you know I know you
would date and Randolph for a while I'm
like that's the best-looking cop out of
my thank you yeah as a couple
store the best cooking cooking like
she's like who is he and I saw you guys
online I know how she's working me I
show it T then you posted something she
goes she is pretty huh I go you know cuz
I know your husband too Jitsu school I
know yeah he said that you guys used to
what is it called scrap roll yeah the
husband's a great guy yeah when did you
get crazy I hope I've been crazy my
whole life I was always like very hyper
I started drinking when I was 10 you
know your buddy brothers Lee system I
had an older brother two years older
than me but I I don't know I just like
was like a crazy kid I was always very
wild I always got in trouble at school I
was always in the principal's office
like starting in second grade like you
know how Santa Claus visits the school
and you have an assembly for Christmas
when I got on his lap I pulled his beard
off and I screamed to everybody he's
fake he's fake because I I wanted to
ruin Christmas like I was crazy from the
start from elementary school did your
parents think I was just always going to
the principal's office and they were
disappointed at me so then I was like
okay well I'm a bad kid so I'm gonna
keep being a bad kid this is what I am
and I you know and I just didn't I truly
did not give a [ __ ] and I'm you know in
the best sense like I'm just trying to
get back to that place on stage now you
know what I mean because I feel like
when you're younger you truly do not
give a [ __ ] okay and I really was that
way you know as class clown and all that
and and then like I got cute you know
when I was like 15 and people started
treating me different so I started kind
of like you know putting it on a little
bit and like my persona changed a little
bit but I've always had like a hard edge
you know started smoking weed when I was
12 I smoked weed every day until I got
sober when I was 26 no pills you said
you know that I didn't really like pills
I liked coke I actually got sent away to
boarding school when I was 15
we're in Switzerland for doing coke too
much at school so they're like we'll
just send you away but they sent me to
Europe where there's no drinking age so
I would just buy coke off the street
from people and
Switzerland they sell coke on the street
they wrap it up in plastic wrap and they
keep it in their mouth and you go up to
people in your like Bamba Bamba which is
coke and in Italian and I was there you
copy
coconut ly yeah all the time yeah I was
I I got alcohol poisoning in Switzerland
and like fell out of like a boat in like
the middle of a lake and like had to be
rescued by people I was always like I
don't know I was just always getting
[ __ ] up and crazy and I was a stripper
for three years which was crazy I
started in Hawaii and then I finished in
New York and how was that it was [ __ ]
crazy
it was it was crazy and I was like
partying really hard and my dad's friend
caught me doing it in New York to him
two separate times my dad's friend like
one guy was like recognized me at scores
and I was like please don't tell my dad
and he was like this is so sick he was
like if you give me a dance I won't tell
him and then when I took off my dress he
goes you look just like your mom
isn't that [ __ ] up yeah and then the
other guy told my dad who caught me his
other friend cuz it was like you know I
lived in New York and everyone New York
City is big but it's small what years
were this this one everybody goes to
scores yeah except me I've never been
yeah now they have scores West that was
on scores West the old one used to be on
the Upper East Side where all the Mafia
[ __ ] was going on and then I think mayor
Giuliani shut that down for a while and
yeah they showed it down completely they
moved it to the west side and then what
open up in that place was sapphires on
the east side little scores history but
it's crazy that I did that because
people hear that today and they would
they're like really you did that yeah
but I I'm a completely different person
today but I definitely
how are you completely different than
when you were 21 yes
people people
completely [ __ ] change you know I
guess I still know you're crazy yeah but
you're not that crazy but it's still
there like I'm still crazy I'm not crazy
when I was 25 yeah 27 crazy 30 crazy but
I'm still crazy yeah how do you see your
change from then so first of all I
completely led with my sexuality then
you know I you know I was an overly
sexual person I you know hooked up with
like anyone you know I'd go to parties
like high on coke and like show people
my boobs you know what I mean I was like
that chick and stay up all night and
like be high and like all I did was go
out to clubs and I wasn't working hard
at all you know I had dreams of wanting
to you know be a writer do stand-up be
an actor you know all the things I'm
pursuing right now but I was just unable
to accomplish those things because I was
an addict so I just you know my thing
was just you know waking up and partying
until the next day and that was it and
I'd think about what I want to do and
talk about it high on coke but I just
you know basically had to burn out and
hit hit a bottom you know with partying
and then once I was able to get sober
was I able to start focusing on the
things that I feel like I was put on
this earth to do you know my dreams in
life and you know I had no ambitions
when I was getting [ __ ] up I mean I
had things I wanted it was impossible
like I was doing that so um you know I'm
a very hard worker today I don't lead
with sexuality I mean when I first moved
here I did the dumbest like I I used to
do like all those you ever see these
girls who do these photo shoots on
Instagram like they wanted like just
like these [ __ ] photo shoots like a
yeah it's like it's a whole thing they
they go to the gym and they do squats
but it's just a little the cameras just
on their ass yeah it's like it's like
you said I'm like I wanted to do comedy
when I moved out here but my friend was
like oh if you do photo shoots with guys
you know guys who have cameras
photographers uh and then they like you
post the pictures like you'll get
followers and I was like oh okay
so I thought I was taking these funny
sexy photos but it's like that's not how
you [ __ ] do you know that's not how
you do comedy that's you have to get on
stage and write jokes but it's like
you're doing all these other things
thinking that's how you're gonna get
ahead you just have to sit down and do
the work and not be a [ __ ] [ __ ] so
I mean I it's like a complete 180
you know what to grow up and grow out of
all these things well I mean there's a
lot of guys who I think listen to the
show yeah
and I up there my cello there's a good
problem to have but like what is it like
being a pretty girl is it is there just
so much stuff being thrown at you and I
guess it hard to almost like to say okay
let me do actually do the work yeah well
to be honest okay so my whole life you
know I was kind of like just a person
who like smoked weed I was like a tomboy
growing up but then when I got hot when
I was 15 and people started treating me
differently I started acting differently
so I'd say from like 15 to like 25 like
I was acting like a dumb [ __ ] and I can
look back on that and say that and I'm
disappointed but in myself but whatever
it is what it is I have the awareness
I've changed as a person I'm not like
that it's all good I've been through
lots of different phases in my life but
basically like you you know you just act
like you're entitled you know you're
used to getting free [ __ ] and you think
you can do whatever act however like
exactly what guys say that that girl is
hot she thinks she [ __ ] could get
everything for free yeah cuz she knows
she can and I and I rode that and you
know and I was just like a party girl
and um and I don't think that I think
it's the way that you carry yourself if
you don't carry yours if you know if you
have self-worth and self-respect
people aren't gonna treat you like that
so I had to build my self-worth and
self-esteem and you know self respect
for myself and stop dressing like a ho
and posting crazy photos if I want to be
seen as a comic and work hard and you
know not flirt with [ __ ] people for
[ __ ] and just do the work
not expect anything and that's like
where I've you know that's the huge
change I've made of my life and the
happen and that makes it makes me happy
to work for things I don't want to
[ __ ] get handed this what was rock
bottom I'd say well when I over you
hallelujah when you think you hit rock
bottom what was sure well I'd say with
getting sober I was 25 26 he's go to
rehab I didn't and I wish I did but my
parents didn't [ __ ] send me and I
Billy please send me and they're like no
just go to AAA or you know 12-step
programs so that's what I did I just
started going to 12-step programs was
hard at first to get sober I want me
time as you try and fail a bunch yeah I
relapsed a bunch in the beginning cuz
it's like I didn't know you could not
smoke weed and be sober or like you
can't take xanax so I had to kept
restarting my sober date but my life
started really changing and uhm and it's
like you're giving you know for someone
who's like an addict you're giving
yourself a chance to finally live
because you're not like living in
reality when you're getting [ __ ] for
me at least when I'm getting [ __ ] up
all the time so you know being sober is
like a completely different I'm like in
the world sort of thing but yeah bottom
was just I was just doing way too much
coke if I had a sip of alcohol I had to
have Coke you know what I mean the
second that alcohol like hits your body
I had that chemical that gets created do
you know I'm talking about yeah so I
have to have Coke and basically I was
just doing too much of it and I felt
myself physically breaking down from it
like my heart would be racing a lot I
was going in the hospital a lot having
to get my heart rate lowered and I was
like I just can't do it anymore and then
the bottom with all that other [ __ ] was
just like it just you know you do stuff
until it just doesn't work anymore and
then you're like what the [ __ ] am I
dealing with my life this is not the
life I was meant to live I want these
other things I have to make a change now
what did your dad say when your friend
like that
so bad I feel so bad he doesn't this is
the [ __ ] no I know I know
no totally he texted me and said you
just broke my heart I told him please
don't tell my dad and then I get a text
at 4 a.m. that says you just broke my
heart and I just you know I went out and
did coke all night that's you know
that's what I do you know what I mean
but you know in sobriety I made it
amends to him you know when 12-step
programs you have to make amends to
people and I sat across from him in a
room and I said I'm sorry for being a
stripper and for putting you through all
that stuff and you know it was actually
like a really nice moment when you make
amends to people some people you don't
know if how people are gonna react and
the people you don't think it's gonna be
a big deal to it's always like the
people who appreciate it the most and
then you realize oh I put these people
through so much [ __ ] and now it's like a
living amends to you know I talked to my
dad on the phone the other day and he
said you know me and me and your mom are
so proud of your work ethic he worked so
hard and like that's the person I am
today and they like you know the
daughter I was supposed to be for them
kind of thing it seems like a phase you
went through and then yeah yeah I went
through a lot of phases it's so we have
running out of the prison I was clean
mm-hmm you know and I joke around in the
podcast is [ __ ] but I really gave it a
go
I'm not gonna lie to anybody I gave it
like a 10-day go and day you had to go
to the groups in the halfway house the
first week you weren't allowed to leave
until you had meetings for jobs issue
like that and the only other thing you
could leave for is for meetings so I got
hip to that when I started going to
meetings I would go to meetings to lie
to myself I'm not gonna lie to anybody I
would just go to meetings and sit there
and daydream and say look at these
[ __ ] idiots
but I remember after the first week
somebody hugged me got a meeting I
started hugging people and for the first
time in a long time I felt good and the
boss naturally will anytime somebody was
good we had to make a bet hmm
like as a cokehead you got to make it
bad like when something is good can't be
like I got we got a rule in this [ __ ]
hey Joey we really like what you did
today I'll [ __ ] that I gotta come to the
lake tomorrow to ruin that good guy
image you know but I still remember
leaving that like I've gone to like four
meetings in a week like four days
straight and it was because I had to
take a bus to no one ha Boulder and take
a bus back to North Baldwin I would see
my girlfriend and I would stop and see
one of my friends and you know I knew
the bus routes but I don't know like
after four meetings that Sunday walking
outside and going that feels really good
you know I'm really doing something good
on my life but you know how that got us
yeah that was snoring and going to the
meetings right like I was a snoring
going to the meetings I wasn't that
disrespectful I would go to meetings to
have an excuse to get high and then on
the way back from the meeting I would
get high and I feel really bad saying
that the name but it's true you know a
lot of people go through those steps
there's a lot of people listening to the
show that are going through those steps
right now goes first it's really hard to
[ __ ] up in the beginning because you
don't know what you feel like you've
never really had that feeling of just
being totally sober like it's so weird
we [ __ ] around in here from time to time
we the Viking in the Sun every sixth and
we're onto something but cocaine I
respect it now now I've watched all
these shows over the years about Marcos
and everything I suspected about the 80s
was true you know this is all our
government [ __ ] our own people you
know they knew about the coke they know
it think that you know when they
realized there was billions of dollars
they just became partners at these
[ __ ] guys and now people who grew up
in the 80s people grew up in the late
70s there's a lot of people [ __ ] up
whenever I talk to my friends in Jersey
we always end that conversation like you
may not be working bro but you're not
this guy like for every 10 guys I went
to school with this six people today are
the [ __ ] up in their 50s like they've
never recovered from that didn't ever
recover from that thank God
I stopped when I did like thank God like
11 years ago I stopped don't and no
rehab no none
I just did the same thing you did I
can't
this can't keep happening I was trying
to stop from about two years you know
there's a rehab on sunset right between
the [ __ ] smoothie place and lebrandt
right across from Hollywood high school
there's a there's a diamond there and
it's like an AEA type rehab facility
uh-huh it's all outpatient yeah there's
a bunch yeah you could sign up like I
signed up yeah I signed up to that thing
it went like three meetings but they
wanted too much like not money they
wanted too much commitment from a guy
like me to be sober [ __ ] that yeah you
know I'm still gonna get AI once a week
how can you do a thing like that yeah
our junkie [ __ ] mind working you know
but I'm happy you made amends with your
parents like I look at my daughter and
I'm like what the [ __ ] she's [ __ ] six
last night she walked into karate and
she told the karate teacher rocked me
like a hurricane
my daughter RPN yeah and she looks at me
the teacher she goes she gets this from
you and I go no I don't know where the
[ __ ] she heard that song you know they
got him in all these movies now all
these movies have music there was listen
to [ __ ] I wasn't listening to it I'm
serious so I have like you know studio
54 a trunk nation I got a bunch of [ __ ]
on there and he had there that's
physical was owned by Olivia newton-john
this one came on 1981 she was singing in
the back
I don't light and go how the [ __ ] you
know this song and she I said some one
of my movies I'll show you tonight that
night sure enough she showed it to me
some Monsters Inc or something like that
Wow she doesn't know it's Olivia
newton-john you don't know who [ __ ]
it yeah but just the fact that she knows
that song but she knew rock you like a
hurricane yeah Here I am that she's told
the teacher Here I am rock you like a
lift at Michoud she gets this from you I
don't know where she got that from to be
in her mother's car
you can't talk her from my daughter
she's a [ __ ] parrot shermanus
whatever the [ __ ] you say the MA I put a
Bruce Lee movie on for cuz we're gonna
Shin Eun this week so she's all things
China that's how I got through the
Chinese restaurant last night and she's
all things China so yeah night I
couldn't sleep I'm just [ __ ] flew and
I got up and I watched
Bruce Lee had just started I don't like
ain't this a [ __ ]
a perfect night Bruce Lee's on end to
the dragon and I was watching they
showed all the boats and should I go I
gotta stop this right now it's taped us
so I taped the floor and the next day we
got home alone talking about China I got
some point I put the Bruce Lee movie on
oh my god
she went [ __ ] apeshit kicking around
there's a scene where she fights she's
six and I just want I taken a Muay Thai
over there because like she got punched
in the face yesterday first of all she
lost two teeth this week oh got no teeth
over it exactly look these two about to
go out and one of them here is missing
she's lost six or seven so far yesterday
the kid punched her right here and I
could see him go down a little bit and
she really wanted to cry but I saw her
Diaz take on how Valdes not even the
Diaz I saw that she came and blocked in
the face then she threw a [ __ ]
straight punch on his face and they go
that's the valve that it's that angle
that she wanted to really cry I put her
in there so she's not scared if I die is
something happens to me she'll never be
scared she'll know how to take a punch
so I put this Bruce Lee thing on me and
then he's fighting his bodyguard the
[ __ ] Hans bodyguard do you know she
stood there and mimicked all of Bruce
Lee's moves and she woke up on it put it
run it back run it back
and then she kept saying kick him in the
eye
Bruce Lee kicked again eh because I told
you they kick him in the eye oh my god
that's so cute so I'm sitting there
making what kind of [ __ ] Savage is
this gonna be you know like yeah Walker
sad it's like the other night you said
to me and I go I gotta go for a stress
test tomorrow I'll stick me those
emissions like you got to face your
fears
she goes you can't be scared daddy you
gotta face your fears you got to go in
there I know yeah I want to be around to
see you be 20 at least she'll be around
she's you ain't going nowhere and I was
laughing I'm like I wouldn't want to see
you it scares the [ __ ] outta me yeah
like I'm trying to I'm trying to raise
it but you gotta have those things she's
gonna hear about addictions
you know I try to write in a notebook
for every day like that's why I asked
you about
that like what your relationship now
them beautiful yeah it's like nothing
happened
yeah I mean like you know I still feel
bad about putting him through that
experience you know that text you just
broke my heart you know what about your
mom
yes you say there were always um she she
knew I
I was surprised that she didn't really
say anything my parents are very okay so
my parents were pretty crazy themselves
like they went to 54 every night my dad
loves quaaludes like I have so many
funny videos what I do for a living he
worked in fashion right now he's kind of
retired he's 70 so he doesn't really
just kind of chill but he worked in
fashion for a long time he was a buyer
my mom was a model when they met and
then she raised us and but they were you
know when they were like laid back like
party people you know they never told me
that they did but I I thought they did
look before you had no choice I know I
know I know
yeah I know that my dad loved quaaludes
though he talks about them all the time
yeah they're the best drug ever [ __ ]
babe yeah I obviously never did them I
hear sometimes people say you can get
them from Mexico but I'm sure it's not
like the real thing or if it's even
possible I don't know I just don't you
know they're the same thing as the raw
RISM with the lemons out of them yes
studio 54 did you ever did you go there
I went there after the heyday okay like
I got damn 84 83 no that's that big
window that real studio yeah they went
there every night like they parted the
line for that they say no when they went
up to the door it's funny they have a
podcast oh I think I heard that too
you're 54 that the Sirius channel has a
podcast on Sunday nights uh-huh and it's
a 50/50 podcast it's either really
really bad top out sheer something sheer
and the bartender from Studio 54 so it's
the original guest list maker Richie
nothing there guy no maybe it's the
original guest list the chick was the
one who made the guest list every night
and the guy was a bar
and they interview people who went to
studio 54 and I've we used to do our
part we do a podcast a lot on Sundays I
don't know how many times I've sent
outside for 10 minutes just Howard or
tears wanted none of my face from a
story that they told like there was this
one couple and he they were dentist she
was a dentist and he was a dentist and
they had kids they told that story that
they would they went to studio five
nights a week yeah like that was what we
did
no we didn't go anywhere else we didn't
go to this place or this place they
would go to studio at 11:00 and stay
till 5:00 and then come home get the
kids bring him downstairs to the house
they lived with him their mother you
know New Jersey yeah and it's like a
Brooklyn it was like two-story houses
where you live upstairs and your parents
move downstairs
they would just drop the kids off on the
way down move feed the kids the whole
thing they would take a nap till 10:00
yeah put the kids to sleep and they take
a nap till 10 o'clock get dressed
go to the studio till 5:00 go home feed
the kids then they would send the kids
to school with with them grandmother and
then they were both gonna sleep till
about 2:00 and go be dentists from 2:00
to 4:00 damn high they never said they
never probably interesting because they
were talking about like people that had
seen that yeah and she was saying that
for years she was invited to sit with
Liza Minnelli hmm and then one day after
a couple years why is me really sad by
the way what is it that you do because
I'm a dentist she lies me like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about I thought you
were a PR because they you know they she
was telling the story about Bob Hope
getting tied up Bob Pollin I don't know
everybody want this to you're 54 oh yeah
what they just to look at it Paul
Castellano from again B knows everybody
with the steel 54 just to look at and
they said one that Bob Hope came and the
guy the owner said go tie them up a
bunch of chicks took those strings and
just try to put zip ties not zip ties
those like you know red balloons like
the strings that balloons like that was
like when there's a party people told
that lace up that [ __ ] confetti
confetti type when they wrote ran around
really and they rolled around them all
these chicks just kept running around
Bob Hope and thought his
repent yeah I can Bob wasn't doing blow
and then they said that's why they went
the goof on Bob I think oh yeah that Bob
on the dance floor
yeah can Bob Hope like those stories of
us
this is documentary now on Netflix it's
not bad it did look it's not bad yeah
it's not the best but it's not bad it's
it's interesting at least look at what
people how they lived in those days like
that was their live studio 54 they slept
for hours a [ __ ] night and they ran
they did quaaludes they did drugs I
can't even think about it
yeah different strokes with different
[ __ ] folks man there was this
incredible place Club it was very small
called Beatrice Inn in New York have you
ever heard of that place it was on
little West 12th and 4th in the in the
West Village and it was incredible and I
feel like it was more of like a modern
day 54 and it was crazy and it was only
like celebrities and socialites and
everyone there did coke out in the open
and it was super super crazy what use
was this was probably 2005 to like 2011
maybe Erno like 2005 to like 2008 or
something and I used to go there every
single night I started going when I was
17 and they would let me in and it was
[ __ ] crazy and I and that's like a
legendary like party Spa in New York
that like I feel like was r54 that yeah
it's it's short-lived but it was it was
very cool very cool know when you came
out here you mentioned that sex club in
Hollywood yeah sanctum it's just [ __ ]
garbage it's so lame
it's like a bunch of rich guys that pay
to belong to that place I've heard about
that place
yeah but people pay yeah have to pay big
money yeah and they they get models to
come in and just confuse girls yeah yeah
I mean I used to love like going to
these crazy kind of parties as like a
voyeur to just kind of check it out and
be like what the [ __ ] is this you know I
don't know I mean now you know now that
I'm a little older like I don't think
I'd give a [ __ ] I'd be like yeah I'll
pass on that but like it used to be fun
for me it'll like go to weird [ __ ] so
you know just something talked about a
story something fun I did the same
yeah larger that like I said sex clubs
weren't the place for me I'd always be
embarrassed yeah but somebody took a
dick out and started sucking the
bathroom a bit of time ago I put that
away that I was embarrassed or something
but I've been to all the other places I
just can't wink I think Kate told me
about that too people are talking about
that oh yeah it still goes on it's
supposed to be like the movie the ice my
church wide shut but I heard it's
disgusting
it's just a bunch of immigrants ha ha
we're [ __ ] little dicks going down
and speaking that language it songs on
and no one was yeah they're just getting
money from losers sorry sorry I feel
like an ass I'm saying I had a
girlfriend that wasn't all that [ __ ] in
LA
and they like we broke up and then she
lasted about a year and a half and she
left here running yeah he's never come
back never she came back once to visit
him like says two that we broke up in 98
I think she left in 2000 but she was
into all that and I'm like you're not
gonna [ __ ] him I think some guy had sex
with him put it up on YouTube oh you
poor the one of those something like
that something bad happen yeah these
people are shitty people yeah you know
I'm sure like all those kind of guys
film people they have sex with you have
no idea there's a camera in the corner
of the room you know I go through
Lankershim at night sometimes and yeah
tribe of Lankershim and there's those
three little massage parlors a
Lankershim from like Riverside to
Magnolia there's three little massage
parlors there's one that's legit like
you go within these guys working in
girls and they massage on the open I
take my wife there yeah forty bucks I
think and leave that yeah great it's
[ __ ] great but the other two I think
I like yeah how do you know one time I
think I went to one accidentally cuz
they were mean to me and they were mad
at me and I was like okay no this is in
New York but I think it was a happy
ending place cuz when I went there they
were like annoyed that I was there and
then I think I want to massage what so
they have to take me and then she was
like kind of like beating me and I think
she was just taking out her anger on me
because I made her lose 70 bucks that
day you
I mean and then I look through the
little hole and there was like baby oil
and a rag and I was like I feel like
this is like a jackoff place they're all
are there pretty much how do you know I
don't know they used to have a website
yeah there was an app I yes an app that
tells you will suck your dick in the
valley to let you [ __ ] like the Red Bank
Maps yeah but live like they remember
like I when I first started dating I
would go to Craigslist dating like they
used to have dating but there's a new
law and because there's prostitution on
Craigslist and all that stuff they
started all those sites down dating or
misconnection both they shed all that
down did you ever respond to a Miskin no
I never had a Miss connection but I did
have it was in the day you never did it
uh Instant Messenger
it's like texting but oh my Wow so I met
I met somewhere on there and it was sort
of like the guy and the girl thing it
was like I would message the girl but
the guy would be like Oh like like tell
her this and to me in and I was I was
like 19 I was fresh out of fresh into
college and like years later I look back
I'm like I was probably just messaging
the guy but like no we're gonna come and
do like the threesome thing and I I was
still a virgin
I was really excited like it was
extended it never happened but I was
like oh yeah I'm just messaging the guy
there's no way there's a girl there all
these places I just don't trust them
well I don't go to them but I what I'm
saying is I really don't trust them
because I guarantee and I told red
madness like two years ago he told I
don't look for cameras yeah I can't well
looking rubber crafts
yeah they had cameras yeah I don't like
I don't with all the celebrities and
idiots in this town that's what they're
waiting for
they're waiting for you to go in there
get a [ __ ]
then call you a come on later and go
really give it to TMZ and we'll [ __ ]
either give us other thousand dollars
that will let people know you got a
[ __ ] in a Chinese place
and that's why I don't trust none of
these people like I wouldn't go to one
of those places and then somebody came
to me I could just rub your dick out
yourself ha ha for the [ __ ] 50 bucks
or whatever you gonna pay it's not worth
getting humiliated like that like I just
think that's just humiliation yeah
you're done look at the [ __ ] so I but
that I don't trust this
I don't trust vagus anywhere where
there's don't rein me like that like
people come I mean how many celebrities
did you see it scores I don't actually
don't remember seeing any really yeah
because a lot of those [ __ ] go
to me you're sitting on all those creepy
yeah I don't it was it's all just like
rich guys Oh everyone there is rich and
you know businessmen mostly I don't
remember seeing any celebrities that I
can think of and now you married yeah
seven months happy yeah you look good
thank you you do a lot of comedy yeah I
see that either you and him go Bobby Lee
from time to time yes yeah a couple yeah
that was very fun we got the double
feature for him it was super fun getting
to go with him he's a good dude Bobby
huh oh he's the best he's crazy
incredible he has the best stories and
he's so kind and he's a really good
person he generous really extremely you
know it's weird that you see him with
his hand [ __ ] up and the hats and
everything was just you and him mm-hmm
it's like the sweetest conversation
whether had would somebody totally
I've known him for I don't know how long
he was a kid when I first met him he was
a kid at the store yeah just come up
from San Diego really big Korean eyes he
smelt like Sam Beck you know yeah he was
just a sweetheart like I've when I saw
him that uh he takes you out you sure
like that out I was [ __ ] buying your
the other thing that you had but I was
really touched by I know put it together
[ __ ] Brody did Tommy yeah buddy
yes yes Eric oh what a with Josh Pope
sent me the other day Josh wolf sent me
the first list
he sent me the first list that we did
together this is the first open mic I
haven't did the Seattle Oh June 26 1995
Wow how did he have the list he went up
there last weekend and the manager came
to the comedy club look at the names on
that list that's amazing this was a hot
first open mic in Seattle Brody Stevens
June 26 1995 Joshua produce Stephens is
a couple people yeah there's a class
Craig Gass is still doing comic cuz he
that was so that way there was a Monday
night and a Tuesday night so that was
the Monday and Tuesday night oh Sh it's
handwritten that's crazy they still have
that thing he had the manager manager
Carl Waldman Holden who's a great great
great I like that he saved that he saved
all the years I like seeing those old
line ups people post those so much today
I have a folder at the bottom bottom of
my desk that's gotta be thicker than
this look it's like three inches yeah
and it was so weird when you first
become a regular at the store you have
to go to the store and look around don't
be like 11:30 and I just steal the
schedule off yeah yeah yeah and put it
in my pocket
I always stole the mainland one like I'm
yeah I'd steal the mainland one and
keeping the wallet so I would tell Club
all this like I would send my promo to
club owners and go here you go [ __ ] oh
yeah I gotta see it pay what tape is the
tape really yeah I love that no tapes
I'm number three I'm following [ __ ]
Paul Mooney what do you want what do you
want you still want to take and then
what they're like alright then they
would hire me I would never say that
smart I would send those things oh just
make copies own I grab stairs the Comedy
Store make 25 copies of them and send
them out with a headshot a bio and the
dates I was looking for
yeah it's a good idea welcome yeah yeah
that's how you do it it's it it's
something that I think it's important I
don't do enough of is
keeping my Mentos like keep my key so I
can look back in 20 years and mean Eric
are like doing open mic sir it's uh I
have all my stand-up papers like The
Comedy Store and I have all the shooting
schedules oh yeah I'm sure I've ever
done they have the big thing they give
you and they give you a little one so
you can put in your pocket I took all
the call [ __ ] the call sheet yeah I took
home all the call sheets at the sides
for the day
Wow so I have a stack of four inches of
just [ __ ] call sheets and I look at
it I'm like I can't [ __ ] believe this
is 20 years ago yeah I shot MADtv 20
[ __ ] years ago to [ __ ] with a dog
like I never believed these things Wow
so but bro I love you to death Chelsea
and you we work together I took you with
me to ice house and once I get more
dates throughout the year in the second
half I'll take in a couple dates thank
you cuz I know you work hard you know I
know it's harder even for a girl yeah an
ugly guy like me ha ha get not stages
[ __ ] but I admire you and I knew that he
got a little bit of the past I didn't
know was that deep with drugs and strip
and I just know he's a little bit of a
past or not I just always like you
smiled you was really sweet to me and I
just remember one night going God get up
there or some people like why he put her
cuz she's beautiful in that way but no
cuz she's a [ __ ] comic and every time
I come here I see it here and she's very
sweet to me show is his high and what
the [ __ ] she works yeah I know what [ __ ]
you put up with yeah so funny thing I
mean you're not working there for the
money right now learning I can't I
applaud those people I really do I know
how hard it is to work that I was a
doorman I hosted a yeah man on Sundays
only mm-hmm only on Sunday she would let
me because I'd be on the road she would
let me host on Sundays and be the
doorman on Sunday but I wasn't the
doorman all night I would just work the
door from week 7 to 10:30 yeah dombarris
do the [ __ ] thing there was enough
doorman they wouldn't say nothing to me
yeah so I was like a mitzi doorman and
she wouldn't say [ __ ] so I know what
it's like
work there and now you know you ever
believe anything anything I really
wanted to get you on the show I'd love
to do your show yeah I would love that
that's it you got a new home you know
the church thank you so much thank you
for having me
don't forget she's on the wouldn't how
many times a week to do your podcast its
weekly so I haven't done it in a couple
of weeks I do it at the store and at my
apartment cuz I've just been too busy
and I was writing working on writing a
pilot with my friends so I didn't have
time but filming a recording one this
week tomorrow but yeah check it out
Chelsea Skidmore show on iTunes and
Spotify and it's mostly weekly and I've
been doing it for about a year now
cuz I've been following you on facebook
for a while I would see you on the time
and then she's the only other
[ __ ] I know that gets Carvel
cakes oh my god better so [ __ ] funny
reason why you're on this podcast right
now I just want a beautiful I just sent
that picture to Steven last night
because sometimes we just send each
other old pictures I can't believe you
just brought that picture and I forgot
to tell you to your face and just now I
said that's right it's the best cake ice
cream cake I was telling him the day
that I go to karma go to Karma every man
got a double column another chocolate
yeah colored sprinkles and whipped cream
and I get a chocolate shake thin and
after I had licked it with sprinkles off
and I get it like a little nub I would
just dip the cone until the milkshake
and lick the cone as I was walking and
drink them that's how much of a gap all
night
yeah like I [ __ ] love it now although
we have one here Carvel your store where
it's in West Ella it's like no they do I
know I know no no that's not about I
walked in there I got aggravated really
yeah it's right across from Century City
coat oh I I don't know my brother used
to work there back in the day I went in
there one yeah I wouldn't do the one
here down here Santa Monica whatever the
[ __ ] it is oh really
right outside am I like a bull that's
the one you're talking about yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah when they first opened I
[ __ ] pull the u-turn I cut people off
I wanted now is past
how much of the cone supposed to be a
dollar really i guess well the floors
down yeah it was I was hot no not good
no bueno they stole the ice cream cakes
a supermarket yeah I go to rap you have
to get one not so [ __ ] good no we won
every birthday yeah there's a carbon
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] what do you
want my condition where I come from
there's a carb okay I so all I know is
cars out yeah have you had sweet lady
Jane no what's this sweet lady Jane is
incredible they have the triple berry
cake it's unreal it's like a short it
tastes like a strawberry shortcake kind
of thing with berries it's alright
strawberry shortcake or these [ __ ]
people still it's [ __ ] it's so short
a new jersey like that that's type of
I've made by Jews at speaking of Baker
not that because I've had the Strawberry
Shortcake these people out here call
strawberry shortcake that's not
strawberry it's that kind of a vibe it's
like a berry cake with cream like it's
it's it's a very famous because I've
only had the original what's fudgie the
whale what's inside either way I read
you the whales one of the cakes all
right Carvalho if you don't know you
don't get the circle one
there's pudgy the well it's just a blue
whale it's gross instead of them giving
like what did when you eat the the
Carvel cake it's vanilla ice cream on
the top with the thing yeah and then the
letters are good that blue yes the icing
is sorry on the side that the white
icing is so [ __ ] good
that cake is made from all icing it's
incredible it's blue so the more that I
see your [ __ ] nose got going like
that any dates anyway you're going I'm
gonna be with Polly at the end of the
month and just like little pop ups in LA
nothing else on the road yet but I think
I'm gonna go out with Bobby again soon
so I just post them all on Instagram you
work yeah you don't know what you're
doing yeah we might get a call next
Thursday nights yeah fly up the [ __ ]
Milwaukee that's a type of [ __ ] yeah
well you are yeah I'm ready
that's good you got one of those calls
this week he'll have to be in
Minneapolis I love it I have to get one
of those little [ __ ] things you see
those kids Big Bird scared to go to the
corner put the credit card I want that
much of course you take one of scooters
to Minneapolis eight million dollars
that one foot will be flatter than ever
oh that won't be flat I looked at
driving there too too long it's like
it's like a day and a half
that's perfect Ewing I'm gonna do for
day you love to say but no no but the
the last shows on Sunday you could do
you two taxes if you leave a [ __ ]
midnight you'll be here by six o'clock
you'll be ready for the plan I know
you'll be here by [ __ ] if you leave
Monday twelve is lunchtime
six o'clock no it's thirty hours of
driving listen Oh thirty hours yeah yeah
you forget about it you'll be yeah we'll
take a plane all right I love you
[ __ ] I got nothing on the books
till June [ __ ] so I get back beside
that I want to thank Chelsea Skidmore
what can they find you Instagram at
Chelsea Skidmore Twitter
xoxo Chelsea Skye I love you say hello
to your husband for me suddenly my love
he's a [ __ ] gentleman I want to thank
you guys I want to thank you for
listening I want to thank you for being
father family do not forget to follow my
girl Chelsea Skidmore you'll see on the
road maybe this year I want to thank the
flying Jew aka the Christ killer okay
the may have washed which thank you guys
for listening cuz your family I love you
[ __ ] all right I want to thank
Chelsea Skidmore I want to thank the
flying Jew but most importantly I want
to thank you guys for listening and for
support in the church I also want to
thank the sponsors one of my favorites
for hims let me explain something to you
premature ejaculation is a nightmare I
lived through it for years all right
it can make you feel down on themselves
and it creates a vicious cycle or sexual
anxiety most guys aren't thrilled at the
thought of opening up to a doctor about
the performance problems they're really
not but having a positive mental state
is good in and out of itself and it'll
also be a key to better lovemaking and
helps guys gain control when crunch time
is that's what we call a win-win
situation now 39 percent of men
experienced this all right you want to
maintain erections for longer now do me
a favor right you're worried about your
timing well it's time you stop worrying
and started lasting longer visit four
hems calm to get convenient and
affordable treatment for your early
arrivals all right they cannot get to
adopt online
who can evaluate you and help identify
the right treatment for you best yet it
could be delivered right to your door in
a discreet packaging this means no more
awkward in personally doctor
appointments you got to spill your guts
none of that stuff so if you want to
slow your roll if you know what I mean
and make the good times last throw the
four headings calm they got you covered
they got men covered okay and right now
the church family gets a special offer
I'll get you started on four hymns for
$10 that's right $10 just go to for
hymns calm slash cocoa to get started
that's four hymns FR hims dot-com slash
cocoa to get started this is what you've
been waiting for
see website for full details and safety
information okay the church is also
brought to you by one of my all-time
favorites zip recruiter you know why
hiring used to be hard multiple job site
stacks of resumes of confusing and
review process but today hiring can be
easy and you have the one place to get
it done you ready write this down zip
recruiter comm slash Church that's zip
recruiter comm slash Church the zip
recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job would
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology in zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find the right people with the right
experience and invites them to apply for
your job as applications comes in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match this is this is
tremendous zip recruit is so effective
that four out of five employees who post
on zip recruiting get quality candidates
through the site within the first day
you heard that right within the first
day and right now with zip recruit is
gonna do it and what I'm gonna do for
you guys the church family is you can
try a zip recruiter for free gratis free
zero zip and cool accom slash church
again that zip recruit calm slash Church
si-hu rch zip recruitni.com slash Church
recruiter the smartest way to hide I
want to thank the zip recruit I want to
thank hims
I want to thank Chelsea I want to thank
the flying
you I want to thank you guys for support
me I got no dates on the books I'm in
New York doing my thing if you see me
say hello and that's it and that's that
we'll be back Monday morning
tick tock Magoo ready to rock your world
again thank you for listening Lee take
this [ __ ] meal Savage